[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner koch
wählt heute gibt's bei mir etwas
schnelles etwas was man gut vorbereiten
kann und zwar mache ich einen
hackfleisch nudelauflauf ich werde zwei
minuten gleich abkochen und die
hackfleischsoße machen und es wird dann
einfach im ofen überbacken und das mache
ich immer ganz gerne wenn ich lust auf
hackfleisch ab und schmeckt eigentlich
echt ziemlich gut wahl mit den
champignons ich brauche dafür 500 gramm
nudeln
ich habe jetzt hier so ganz kleine feine
nudeln genommen so schmeckt mir eben am
besten
die haben jetzt so eine kochzeit von
ungefähr sechs bis acht minuten und ich
koche sie dann einfach kürzer dann habe
ich hier 500 gramm rinder hackfleisch
habt ihr zwiebel und knoblauchzehe 2
esslöffel tomatenmark 250 milliliter
gemüsebrühe und 400 milliliter milch
eigentlich macht muss mit sahne aber ich
finde über hat doch schon so viel käse
mit drin dass man auf mich nehmen kann
und einfach bisschen fett reduziert das
ganze macht ich brauche zwei bierchen
mozzarella und 4 200 gramm emmentaler
oder gouda und hier habe ich noch 250
gramm champignons und noch meine gewürze
salz pfeffer chili und oregano und ich
werde jetzt das ganze parallel machen
als ich werde auf der einen seite nudeln
abkochen oder auf der anderen seite
einfach das hackfleisch und die
hackfleisch so zu machen
es gebe ich zuerst mal das hackfleisch
in meine heiße pfanne
da habe ich bereits ein esslöffel
olivenöl drin und braten und kann ihn
wäre schon mal die zwiebel klein
schneiden und die knoblauchzehe auch
klein machen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das hackfleisch krümelig
gebraten und jetzt kommen die zwiebel
und die knoblauchzehe noch mit dazu und
werden einfach so drei bis vier minuten
mit gebraten und in der zeit kann ich
dann schon mal meine champignons
einschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die champignons hier noch
mit dazu und die dürfen auch noch mal
drei bis vier minuten mitbraten
[Musik]
es gebe es vier das tomatenmark noch mir
das zu und das ist auftritts mit fragen
und in der zwischenzeit habe ich auch
bereit meine nudeln schon abgekommen sie
warten jetzt hier
ich habe sie nämlich nur so etwa 45
minuten kochen lassen dass das netz so
weich werden
und jetzt lösche ich das fleisch mit der
gemüsebrühe ab die post gleich auf die
menschen mit dazu
und würde das gleich noch mit pfeffer
und den anderen gewürzen und jetzt
gleich noch mal aufwachen und so etwa 56
minuten köcheln bis eben die flüssigkeit
sei ein bisschen weg ist
[Musik]
mit dem salz minister bisschen spaß aber
umgehen weil er schon gemüsebrühe drin
ist und während das jetzt gleich kocht
werde ich schon mal eine auflaufform mit
olivenöl bepinseln
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich den nudeln in meine
auflaufform und ihr könnt ja wirklich
jeder beliebige nudeln eben alles was
euch am besten schmeckt
die verteile ich jetzt hier so ein
bisschen meine waren ebenso ein bisschen
klebrigen habe ich einfach nochmal
heißes wasser drüber laufen lassen und
jetzt kommt da direkt die
hackfleischsoße drauf ich mach das jetzt
mal so
einmal verteilen man könnte jetzt auch
bisschen vermisse das habe ich auch
schon mal gemacht aber so finde ich es
einfach schöner seht ihr im hübsch aus
schmecken tut's gleich und jetzt habe
ich hier meine zwei käsesorten die habe
ich ja eben bereits schon klein
geschnitten
also den mozzarella habe ich einfach mit
messer in scheiben geschnitten und den
emmentalern mit der küchenmaschine klein
gemacht und jetzt verteile ich erst
einmal zarella drüber und dann noch den
emmentalern ich denke wie eine bombe
sagen womit wir es zu würzig geworben
worden ja dass wer zuhört sich und der
mozzarella wie das so schön cremig und
das mag ich ganz arg aber statt dem
emmental kann man ja auch gouda nehmen
[Musik]
und das ist halt der grund wieso ich
milch und sahne genommen habe ich glaube
mit sahne wir das ganze bis jetzt so
fertig geworden durch den ganzen käse so
und so gebe ich das jetzt in den
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 25 bis 30
minuten wenn ihr merkt dass der käse
schmilzt unschön gold hauen wird könnte
ich rausnehmen und ich werde in dieser
zwischenzeit schon mal einen leckeren
feldsalat vorbereiten passt nämlich gut
dazu
[Musik]
bei uns ist essen jetzt fertig und ich
habe den auflauf wird so ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen damit ich ihn einfach
mittel besser schneiden kann also
kratzer zehn minuten stehen lassen dann
verbrennt man sich vom essen mit zorc
und ich sehe wie lecker aussieht
ich mag meine große stücke haben hat gut
gefrühstückt
aber frei uns jetzt alle aufs
mittagessen
[Musik]
wo es jetzt gleich probieren machen ich
so und ich weiß wie heißen die leute
denken 2010 abgekühlt gewesen nein es
ist direkt aus stellt aus dem backofen
dass sich abgekühlt sonst könnte ich das
ganz gerne zurück schneider
wieso dann ist da noch richtig ich hatte
nur noch 90 grad heiß
statt 200 das mache noch mit dazu
[Musik]
kriegt das firma und ich habe jetzt so
eine leckere salate und zwar an
feldsalat mit einem leckeren senf sahne
essig dressing
[Musik]
ja
wolf heißt aber gern ich bin vor allem
die hackfleisch füllung die ist nämlich
so richtig schön wird sich und das passt
super zu den nudeln und nur grüner salat
oder hals und feldsalat oder einfach ein
bunt gemischter salat passt super dazu
mein rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf
sex - blog.de und ich würde mich freuen
wenn es nach macht und mir dann auch ein
foto auf instagram oder facebook
geschickt und mir einmal wie es euch
geschmeckt hat bis zum nächsten mal
vielleicht hab gedacht wirklich noch was
sagt ja ich habe jetzt auch ins darüber
stimmt erster stelle manchmal können wir
jetzt auch bei den zugaben folgen
das kann fast alles nur ein spaß
[Musik]